♪ Born in 1966 ♪
♪ He turned his life around ♪
♪ He wasn't doing so hot ♪
♪ Rich Roll ♪
♪ He got rid of that weight and he gained a lot of wisdom ♪
♪ He lives in a tent ♪
♪ Rich Roll ♪
Thank you all so much for playing along,
and I hope you have a wonderful night.
And I'd like to welcome to the stage, Mr. Rich Roll!
(fast guitar strumming)
Hey, everybody. Welcome to "Roll On".
We're an athlete/podcaster/writer,
and a journalist/author/mask-wearing shark lover,
rip headlines from the internet and real world life
and wax on matters of interest,
try to make sense of the world.
Today, we've got a few interesting matters to unpack.
But the thrust of today is celebrating
that little book that you're reading right there, Adam.
What are you reading?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, are we on?
Is this live? Is this thing live?
Is this the hot mic?
This is.
I'm reading this great memoir; it's captivating.
I think you should check it out.
Actually you're reading the first version
before I revised it.
First edition, baby.
You need to read this one, I think.
Oh really, is that the better version?
This is better, yes.
So I have the first version and it's signed by the author.
"Adam, let's hit the point soon.
Thanks for being you, my friend."
Is that the one that I gave you
when we did our first podcast together?
It is, it is.
I had a Kindle copy, and then you sent me this one,
or you gave me this one.
I'm glad that you still have it.
Yeah, man.
When I did the New York Times story on you for a backstory,
yes, I wrote a Rich Roll in New York Times sports story,
I reread it and love it, of course.
I appreciate that.
Yeah, man.
You being on "Roll On" is just me paying you back
for that New York Times story.
That was the deal that we struck.
Has it been that useful for you?
(both laugh)
No, it was great.
That was in the wake of Otillo.
Otillo.
Yeah, no, it came out in the wake of it.
Right, yeah, but we did the research prior.
That would never made the print edition, though.
Listen, man--
I'm still grinding on that.
I just work here.
(both laugh)
I know.
Anyway, good to see you, my friend.
Good to see you.
Glad to be back in the podcast studio with you.
And yes, we're gonna talk about "Finding Ultra".
Why are we talking about "Finding Ultra"?
Because this week marks the 10th anniversary of this book.
So I thought it would be fun--
Congratulations.
To celebrate that a little bit,
have a little peek through the rear view.
I'm having trouble talking today.
Anyway, yeah, we're gonna have a little discussion
about the art of memoir and just writing in general
and I think it's gonna be cool.
But before that, how goes it, my friend?
It's good.
I've been--
So you just said you were good.
I know you.
You said, you think people are complaining
that every time I ask you how you're doing
you say you're good.
No, they did complain.
Then you just did it again.
They did complain.
And then I came up with my high jinks, my intro high jinks.
But then the intro high jinks got--
You just pivoted back to your--
Yeah, so then I went back to my muscle.
But to be honest--
How are you doing really?
If you really wanna know,
I've been deep in the deadline cave
and I have a deadline beard to show for it.
You do.
If you're not watching.
I think you should just continue with the beard.
Now it's moved past the growing down and out
and it's moved into the round phase.
So I'm dangerously close to having a half circle of hair
that just arcs around my face.
Yeah, I know the feeling.
That's why I just shaved mine off,
'cause it was in Chia Pet stage.
Yeah, that's where I'm at.
It's jowly. It's real jowly.
It gets good when it gets long enough
where you can kinda bring it down.
But that's a full commitment.
When I shaved mine the other day,
I thought about keeping the mustache.
I was this close.
That would've been pretty--
And I chickened out.
I'm actually thankful
I'm not staring at a mustache right now.
That would be hard to--
It's distracting.
Nobody needs that.
(Adam laughs)
But this is a deadline beard.
It's kind of like a cousin to the hockey playoff beard.
Shout out to my brothers and sisters up in Canada.
Not that there's anything wrong with playoff beards.
I like playoff beards.
I used it once in Nicaragua
when I was on Lonely Planet jag,
a deep, I've done like back to back to back
Lonely Planet assignments
and the last one was in Nicaragua and they,
it was me and one other writer,
and he lived in Guatemala so he had first choice
and he picked all the places that tourists actually go,
and then three quarters of the geographic region
of Nicaragua where tourists never go he gave to me.
So I was like, literally, like in the jungles.
I mean, it was great stuff.
I loved being out there, but like I don't know
that anybody will ever have used my material for,
maybe Peace Corps volunteers have used it,
but by the time I got to the jungles,
I was like so whacked that, like, I just couldn't shave.
I had like, my nails were growing.
I was like a beast.
And I showed up in a Costa Rica hotel
two days before my flight home and like Christmas time
and went to the check-in desk and they thought that,
they did not look happy to see me.
Right, do you have photographic evidence of this?
I don't know. I think I must.
You should throw that out on Instagram.
I must, I must.
On Thursday when this goes out as a companion piece.
Well, it's--
I need a visual.
Yeah, it's 10 years since I've joined Instagram.
So we both have 10-year--
Congratulations on being--
(both laugh)
I thought you'd like that.
We can all lament that.
But I have been just writing
and making oatmeal for Zoom in the mornings
and then doing some running.
I'm 75 miles into that 100 mile challenge
we spoke about last time for Giveback Homes.
The Giveback homies sent us some hats.
And I've been swimming like once a week.
I need to swim more.
My SWOLF is suffering.
What is SWOLF, by the way?
I've never heard that before.
You never heard of SWOLF stroke?
It's like a stroke score that like comes up on my Garmin.
Oh, I have no idea.
I don't pay attention to that stuff.
No?
No.
I'm a purist naturalist when it comes to swimming.
You swim naked?
I have. Not recently.
But yeah, with all the kind of data metrics on swimming,
I mean, I wear a Garmin
so that I can keep track of my yardage
and time and stuff like that, but I don't look at cadence
or any of the other metrics that tracks--
Doesn't bother you, it doesn't matter,
your stroke rate doesn't even register for you?
I've just been doing it so long
that I don't rely upon that for anything meaningful.
Just feel.
Yeah.
I like it.
What does that stand for even?
You know what, I thought you would know.
No, I don't know.
SWOLF--
Maybe this is why swimmers are so much faster now
than they were when I was coming up.
It's a combination of stroke count
and time taken in the water,
and is often used as a measure for your swimming efficiency.
Ah, so how much forward propulsion
are you getting per stroke kind of--
Yeah.
Yeah, I get it.
That's helpful.
Maybe I should look at that.
You seem like a guy that would,
you'd probably have a really good SWOLF.
That would mean that I need to be swimming.
I'm not right now.
Yeah, how are you? What's going on?
What's going on with you?
Oh man, Adam.
Yeah, talk to me, bro.
The back is not good.
What's going on?
Which is one of the reason why we're not gonna do
a check in with Chris Hauth today.
It's really painful right now.
If I try to do anything physical,
the next day I have a real struggle.
So first of all, we shared a couple weeks ago about this,
I received, I was just inundated with emails
and DMs from people so I appreciate everybody's
sort of sympathy and concern.
That means a lot.
It also came with a lot of recommendations,
a lot of, "Check out this guy.
Here's my protocol.
Here's how I solved my back problem."
And that's great.
I have to sift through it and figure out
what else I can or should be doing
beyond the protocol that I'm currently engaged in
'cause I'm not experiencing any kind of relief.
If I do nothing, then it's a little bit better.
But I was in D.C. the other weekend
visiting my parents and I had a little speaking gig,
I couldn't resist the temptation of going out for a jog.
D.C. is such a great city to run in.
The weather was perfect.
So I thought, "All right, I'm just gonna do
the slowest run ever," like almost a walk,
like a really gentle jog
just so I can cruise around the mall, which I did,
and I was very grateful to be able to do.
And I felt okay while I was doing it,
I didn't do anything hard, I didn't push myself at all.
And the next day, I was like, oh, I couldn't sit up in bed.
Really?
Yeah.
And I haven't been back to the pool.
So I'm pretty much benched right now and it's challenging.
It's much easier for me to train.
The physical exertion is so tied to my mental health
that I'm not happy about it,
but this is where I'm at right now
until I figure out a path forward that is,
got some daylight at the end of it.
Is it a herniated disc type situation?
No, it's not.
It's spondy, my L4 protrudes about a centimeter
towards my gut, like forward, it's out of alignment,
and it puts pressure on the nerves
that have created a lot of foot pain
and some numbness in my left foot
and just general discomfort.
And I think the muscles that surround my spine
are working so hard to keep it all intact
that they just get really tense.
And like your back, unlike,
like if my shoulder was bothering me, I could go running.
If my knee was bothering me, I could go swimming.
But with this, every which way that you move
is impacted by your back obviously.
So I literally can't do anything without pain.
So even if I sit for an extended period of time,
like at the end of this podcast, when I go to stand up,
I can't stand up straight.
So not great.
But given that I can't run,
I still can rock the new Salomon--
You still got the runner's calves.
Yeah, I know.
Those are from my mom.
Those are there no matter what.
You've always had them.
Yeah, it's all show, no go Adam.
But these are the new Salomon CLA collaboration shoes.
Looking good.
Some kind of weird leopard print.
I don't know exactly what that is, but pretty dope, right?
Yeah, those are dope, man.
I love 'em.
I remember you posted about all the different collabs.
They all look great.
Salomon, you know what--
It's all about collabs.
Salomon, I'm running on Salomons right now.
Good, you should be.
I would take it personally if you weren't.
(both laugh)
Don't make this weird, Rich.
But yeah, no, I love those.
I don't have the fancy new collab Salomons.
Right.
They don't wanna give those to me.
But on the subject of collabs,
because collabs is where it's at,
I'm thinking, "What should the RRP collab should be?"
And then I thought, "Well, this is a collab.
This is a Roll-Skolnick collab."
It is.
Right here.
And it's that sought-after.
The whole is greater than the sum of its parts.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
There we go.
Thank you for that.
But I like our collab.
I have a zone two question for you
on the subject of running shoes.
I know it's trying to bring your, I've put the spotlight,
we've put it on you and then I'm bringing it back to me,
but I've been zone twoing back,
I'm back since running a bit more this month
and swimming less, I got my zone two for,
to under 10 minutes a mile now.
Good.
How did you calculate your zone two?
Just through my Garmin.
Mm, not reliable.
I know, that's all I got.
What am I gonna do?
Well, there's lots of protocols.
I should send you to a lab
and have you do a proper lactate test.
Let's do it.
Done.
All right.
There's a place in Santa Monica, if it's still there.
I haven't done one in years.
I love to do that.
But I'm getting a lot of questions about zone two.
We're getting Dr. Peter Attia on the podcast
I think in June, right?
Oh, cool.
It's when we scheduled it.
He's quite the authority on zone two
so we're gonna do a deep dive on that.
But the proper way to calculate and measure your zone two
is to do it in a clinical setting,
either on a treadmill or on a stationary bike
where you basically undergo this protocol,
the last time I did it I brought my bike in
to a place in Santa Monica, they hook it up to a trainer,
you warm up for 5 or 10 minutes,
and then you start at a certain wattage,
I think, if memory serves me,
we started at something really easy like 100 watts,
and every four minutes you increase the wattage 10 watts
and you prick, you have your finger pricked
for blood lactate, you calculate your heart rate
at that interval point and you give your perceived effort,
like how hard is this on a scale of 1 to 10,
and then you just keep increasing the wattage until failure
and then you plot those metrics on a graph.
And you can see when you get this crazy uptick
is where you're going from your anaerobic energy system
to your anaerobic energy system.
And true endurance is reflected when that upward tick
is way down the line in terms of wattage.
And instead of like a hockey stick,
it's a more gradual curve upwards.
You're always trying to push that uptick out
as far to the right as possible.
And it's pretty revealing.
Like you think you're fit or you're doing a certain thing
and then you get a proper test and you're like, "Holy shit,"
like, "I go from my aerobic system
into my anaerobic system at the snap of a finger
when I hit this exertion level."
And the idea is to push that exertion level
as far to the right as possible
so that that switch from one energy system to the next
is sort of protracted as far out
in terms of energy expenditure as possible.
Or effort.
Well, I look forward,
I wanna do that because I'm just so bored at running
like over 10-minute miles.
It's like hard to keep doing it
and I don't feel like I'm getting,
I mean, I am getting a little bit faster but,
like at the zone two,
but it's like I wanna be able to be a little faster.
So it's like--
Well, zone two works.
It takes a lot of time if you're just doing it
and doing it and doing it,
but you need incredible consistency with it.
If you're just running three times a week in your zone two,
it's gonna take a lot longer
before you can hit a faster pace at that same heart rate.
But this is a longer conversation.
Okay, let's move back to you.
How's your career in NFL broadcasting going?
Yeah, this is hilarious.
I tweeted this out the other day.
So this guy, Conor Orr wrote an article
for Sports Illustrated entitled
"10 Dream Candidates for an NFL Broadcast Booth,"
where he's reflecting on the Tom Brady deal,
the $375 million deal to get Tom Brady in that booth,
and thought, "Who else would be good,"
or, "Who would be better," and he lists a bunch of people.
And at the very bottom of the article,
I get nominated along with Steve Magness,
who was recently on the podcast,
that episode hasn't gone up yet.
"A rotating cast of performance science experts:
Steve Magness, Rich Roll, David Goggins, et cetera."
(laughs)
Those are three good names.
So yeah, I mean, I'm honored,
but the hilarious and ironic thing is that like I know,
anybody who knows me, knows I know nothing about football.
Trapper, my stepson, is an NFL fanatic, he knows everything,
so I emailed him this story and I said,
"This will give you a good laugh,"
'cause he knows how little I follow it these days.
Well, yeah, I mean, you're,
I mean, you're not a ball sport guy at all.
I'm not.
Right, yeah.
No, I'm into the obscure sports.
Yeah, you're kind of like,
that's why the mustache would work,
you're a hipster sports fan.
I am indeed hipster.
Is that what it is?
I don't know.
You're into curling.
Yeah, here's, let me just highlight this
for the YouTubers.
So yeah, Goggins.
Goggins would be good.
He would be good.
"Magness, Roll, and Goggins
have all written about the source of our internal drive,
about great leaders and exceptional people.
Having them put a coach in a psychiatrist's chair
during the week would be more instructive to us
as a football-watching society
than a decades-removed former player
more interested in catching the red eye."
(laughs)
I love how salty he is about the typical broadcast booth.
I know. So yeah, thank you for that.
I am touched and honored.
Conor Orr.
And as I tweeted, although I'm lacking in knowledge,
I'm sure Steve Magness can bring me up to speed
with all his track and field expertise
and I'm sitting by the phone waiting for it to ring.
(both laugh)
But you'd be asking the play by play questions like,
"So how many downs do they get?"
Right.
(Adam laughs)
I'm not that bad.
I used to go to Redskins games,
now the Washington Football Club.
Can't say that.
Can't say that anymore.
Growing up, my dad would--
Commanders.
My dad's a huge football fan.
The Washington Commanders.
I grew up watching tons of football.
And then when I became an adult, I just stopped.
But I love my dad and Lord knows he loves football.
Aw, look at that.
Anyway, what else?
What else? How was D.C.?
It was good. I got to see my folks.
Got to do like a little speaking gig there,
and it was the first time that I'd seen them
since before the pandemic so that was good.
And yeah, caught a screening here in LA
of "Blue Velvet" yesterday,
Sunday afternoon, 3:30 screening at the Alamo Drafthouse--
That's amazing.
In Downtown Los Angeles.
Of "Blue Velvet",
which I highly recommend seeing in a real movie theater.
I hadn't seen it in like 20 years.
Were you the only non-stoned person in the--
Probably.
In the audience?
But, interestingly, Timothee Chalamet was there
watching the movie as well.
Really?
So little only in LA star-sighting situation.
And then I thought, "That's pretty cool,"
like a teen heartthrob, who could be doing anything,
is catching a 3:30 in the afternoon screening
of "Blue Velvet."
And then I thought a little bit more about it,
and I thought, well, okay, he's the star of "Dune",
David Lynch made the first "Dune"
and Kyle MacLachlan played his character in "Dune",
so here he is watching Kyle MacLachlan
in a David Lynch movie, the guy whose role he's reprising,
latest iteration of "Dune".
I thought that was pretty cool.
It is cool.
Anyway.
It'd been cooler if the guy that played the worm
also happened to be there.
That's true.
Who is that guy?
The giant worm?
What if like Timothy was there
and then the giant worm was like,
and then they look at each other like awkwardly
and then they like, they don't sit together--
This joke's going nowhere.
(laughs)
All right, let's take a quick break
and we'll be back with some pretty interesting news
from the world of obscure hipster sports and endurance.
Love it.
(enlightening music)
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated by scores of beautiful
and brilliant people who have amazing stories to share,
those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down
the most compelling prophets on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast,
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer,
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book "Voicing Change Volume II."
More than mere words on paper,
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration, and timeless wisdom
that transpires each week on the Rich Roll Podcast.
The first edition of "Voicing Change"
was a beautifully rendered book
worthy of display on any coffee table.
And volume two follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication,
replete with interview excerpts, essays,
and stunning photography,
making for an exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained within.
"Voicing Change Volume II"
available now while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
And we're back.
So this first story that we're gonna get into,
Adam, is bananas.
It is.
It's the story of Anna Moriah Wilson, Mo Wilson, who is,
was a rising star in cycling, in gravel cycling,
who was murdered the other day,
in a story that is basically deserving
of any kind of true crime Netflix series.
Because the details behind this are just crazy,
especially for anybody who follows endurance sports
and particularly the relatively obscure world
of gravel cycling, which I do.
You follow gravel cycling?
A little bit, not super closely.
But it's an up-and-coming sport and it has its stars.
And this young woman had just arrived in Austin
in preparation for a race.
And she was like dominating all year, right?
She was like--
Yeah, she's been crushing.
She's been dominating the sport.
And a lot of people are thinking
like she's the next Coming,
like she's like the best female cyclist in this discipline.
25 Years old, she just had quit her day job
and was going pro--
To go pro.
Like full time, yeah.
So she arrives in Austin.
She's staying with a friend.
And she hooks up with this guy, Colin Strickland,
who is a very successful male gravel cyclist,
who lives in Austin.
They had had a little bit of a dating thing.
Colin's, I think, live-in girlfriend,
Kaitlin Marie Armstrong, who's been with for a while,
they had a period where they broke up for a couple weeks.
Colin and Mo got together during that period of time,
but it was short lived, Mo left.
He got back together with Kaitlin.
Anyway, while Mo was in town,
Colin took her swimming and out to dinner
and allegedly dropped her back off at this apartment
where Mo was staying with her friend.
And later that evening,
the friend returns home to discover Mo dead
in the apartment.
At this point in time,
it appears that all eyes are on Kaitlin Marie Armstrong
as the alleged perpetrator of this violent act.
Not just all eyes. There's a murder warrant.
Yeah, there's a murder warrant out for her.
And US Marshals are trying to find her.
Surveillance cameras have her black Jeep
driving right by the house in the time period
surrounding the murder.
Colin and Kaitlin both have registered firearms.
Nine millimeters, and hers is the one they are,
they have a very high degree of certainty fired the bullets.
Yeah, and there's some evidence of Kaitlin's jealousy
over Colins's relationship with Mo.
So much so that, I believe there's some
less than honest statements that were made to the police
about the extent of their relationship.
I know Colin had like changed Mo's name in his phone
so that Kaitlin wouldn't know
who he was speaking with or texting and--
Never a good sign.
There's another source that told the police
that Kaitlin was extremely upset about this relationship
and had said some things
that turned the police's eye on her as well.
So this is a crazy story.
Yeah, she said, she's quoted as saying
that she wanted to, like a friend of hers tipped the cops
that she said that she wanted to kill Mo, I think.
Right, exactly.
And so this story now has become
like a big mainstream story.
It's not just a story within the insular world
of gravel cycling.
There's a New York Times article about it.
The New York Post covered it pretty comprehensively.
The Daily Beast covered it.
E! Online has covered it.
At this point in time, we're recording this on Monday.
My understanding is that they have not yet
picked up Kailtin,
like they can't find her at this moment in time.
There's an arrest warrant out for her
but she's not in custody.
Tommy Lee Jones and the crew are trying to find her.
Exactly.
It is.
It's the "US Marshals."
The "US Marshals"
are like on the hunt for her at this very moment.
This is a yoga teacher who did this.
Right, she's yoga teacher.
And Colin and her were, had a business together
where they would renovate trailers, like Airstreams I think,
and she was also, she's also a real estate agent in Austin.
So this is just--
Crazy.
Very sad.
By all accounts,
Mo was somebody that was pretty beloved.
Everybody really adored her.
And she had this huge life and career ahead of her
and her life was taken.
Shocking.
In a violent act of murder.
It's just unbelievable.
Yeah.
So I don't know, what do you make of this?
Well, I make of two things.
I don't wanna make, it's not political.
But to me, it's like anytime I see a gun story,
I think wouldn't it be great if it was harder to get guns?
Because typically, if there was no guns involved,
if this was in a country like New Zealand or Australia
and Kaitlin couldn't get the gun,
maybe she would've been more
like Tonya Harding and Nancy Kerrigan
and like a crowbar to the leg or something
but something that she could survive.
So I guess that's the only thing I can take away from it
other than it just shows you
that you just don't know who people are.
'Cause I can't imagine
that Colin would've been with somebody
that he thought was cable of something like that.
And so that's a little scary
'cause it makes you wonder like,
just makes you question what we're all capable of.
I had that feeling the other day, not to get it too dark,
like I go from the gun control to dark, inner darkness,
but do think we're all, we all have a darkness inside us
and we all are, like every human being is capable
of shit we can't even imagine, I think,
and just a lot of us are a lot better at managing ourselves.
And this is obviously somebody who was troubled.
So I'm very sorry to hear it and crazy story.
And hopefully they find Kaitlin
and there's some sort of justice for the families
and I feel bad for everyone involved.
Colin issued a statement.
He basically said he admitted that they had had
a brief intimate relationship in October of 2021,
but that it was over and their relationship is currently
or was currently platonic.
But there does seem to be some questioning
around how honesty's being about
the extent of their relationship.
I mean, the rage that Armstrong kind of held
speaks to something different.
And there is this video evidence here in this E! story.
It says, "Police noted in the affidavit
that a surveillance video showed a dark colored SUV being,
bearing a bicycle rack stop near the home
one minute after Wilson entered it."
I mean, that's pretty damning.
And Armstrong had confronted Mo about dating Strickland,
like there was an altercation on some level prior to this.
So there's a bit of a history.
So it's freaking--
But it's one thing about being dishonest
and running around behind your partner's back,
and I'm not saying that that's great behavior,
but like, I mean--
And murdering somebody in cold blood.
Yeah, I know.
It's like
Colin said that he hadn't talked to Kaitlin also
since like May 13th or something,
so, obviously, there was something before this
that was a breakdown.
I just feel bad for him.
I feel bad for him.
I feel obviously horrible for Mo's family.
I thought that they have a very classy statement
at the end of that Daily Beast story, I think it was,
where they're just saying,
"It's tragic and horrible these events are.
Please remember who Mo was and what,
she chased her dreams, she was, had a positive energy,"
and they take heart that people are mourning with them.
And you really can't respond to this any better than that
so kudos to them.
Right. I believe there's a GoFundMe set up also
to raise money for the family.
Final thing, one of the better articles about this
is in the Boston Globe.
And there's a piece in it about the person
who called the cops, who had a relationship with Armstrong
and said that Armstrong became furious
and was shaking in anger when she was made aware
of Strickland's relationship with Wilson.
"Armstrong told the caller Armstrong was so angry,
Armstrong wanted to kill Wilson.
Armstrong then proceeded to tell the caller
Armstrong had either recently purchased a firearm
or was going to."
Right, I mean it's--
So that doesn't look good.
That's why I say it comes down to access to firearms.
She probably could've gotten a permit anyway
'cause if she didn't have any background checks,
but if you look at,
we're not gonna talk about Buffalo today,
but if you look at that situation
where that person was red flagged,
they had gun control laws, still could get it,
it just shows that even those laws aren't enough and,
'cause like nobody would, it's the Gladwell argument.
If there were no guns, nobody would be dead,
like it's bottom line.
He uses that argument with, in his last book about suicide.
If you don't have the means to do it,
most people would, that impulse would go away
and they'd survive.
So it's like he's shown that.
And it's the same true with this stuff.
Like the darkness that she felt might have passed
if she didn't have a nine millimeter sitting at home.
Right, right.
During that rageful moment.
So that's not an excuse for her 'cause she made the,
that's, it's a horrible act, and I'm not making any excuses,
but we can't take that out of this.
Sure. So more will be revealed.
At some point, the US Marshals are gonna find Armstrong.
So this story will continue.
And we'll be reporting it here for you, folks.
Yeah, we will. We will.
What are we calling that?
What's this segment?
Our collab, yeah, like true crime and endurance.
True crime and endurance.
Hopefully, this is not gonna be a recurring
segment of the show.
All right, let's move on.
To kind of switch gears on this whole thing,
there was this piece in the New York Times
written by your editor, I believe.
Yes, Talya Minsberg. Shout out.
These 90-year-old runners have some advice for you,
and it's pretty great.
I love it.
This video of like these old dudes on the track,
like throwing it down, and interviews,
and incredible portraits with these elderly people,
reflecting on their running careers.
And I just love this piece.
I think it's great.
Like look at these portraits--
Amazing
Of these guys.
Guys in their 80s and 90s.
80s and 90s. And women.
There's like two women that always face off in like,
in every event or something like that.
(both laugh)
That just go at.
I know, I know.
And they all basically say, "Just keep moving." right?
That's the idea.
Basically, yeah.
Yeah, this woman, Lillian, Ashley is 93.
She says, "I guess you just have to have the love to race,
the determination to just do it."
I love, there's a consistent thing
when you talk to older people
and you ask them questions like this.
Their answers tend to be pretty straightforward and simple.
It's like, "Just keep moving.
Don't think about it.
Just gotta get out and get after it."
Mm-hmm, I think about like it,
the La Jolla Cove has a group of old timers
that always swim the cove.
And you see 'em and sometimes they'll like be limping in
and limping out, but then they get in the water
and they're like free, their bodies are free
and they can like move
and they come out and they're so stoked.
There's this story, my buddy John Moore,
who I swim with a lot, or used to prior
when I had the time to swim more often,
now I swim when I can with him.
But he loves this story, where he was there
and he watched this happen,
where this old timer comes out of the water.
It was like a 57 degree water day
and he's, of course, not in a wet suit.
And someone says, "How was it?"
"Oh, it was great."
"Did you see anything?"
"No, no, no, the visibility was terrible."
"Oh, okay.
"And what was the water warm?"
"Oh no, no, no, it's freezing right now."
"Okay, but was it nice?"
"Oh, it was great."
He was just like beaming.
(laughs)
That PMA, positive mental attitude.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't underestimate.
I feel that with these photos.
Yeah, it's pretty cool.
I saw a little video on Twitter this morning.
Somebody had posted it, I can't remember,
but it was a video clip of the master's 100 yard dash
and some guy, I think he was 60, ran like a 131
and there's a video of him running
and he looks like a pro, like he's throwing down.
131 on a 100?
Yeah, yeah.
Geez.
Let me see if we can find that.
Do you think I could beat one of these guys in the 100?
Probably.
Okay.
Depends on your zone too.
I looked at the times.
(laughs)
I'm not fast, but--
You looked at the times.
I wanna make sure I could beat 'em.
Yeah. I don't know, maybe not.
Maybe not.
They're more seasoned competitors.
All right, let's talk a little bit about this
Sub-Seven-Hour Ironman attempt.
People that listen or watch the show
know how fond we are of the Norwegian experiments.
Kristian Blummenfelt, Gustav Iden, Olav Aleksander Bu.
I just scheduled Olav and Kristian for the podcast.
It's gonna be, it's gonna go down mid-October.
Beautiful.
And record separate episodes
with both of them, so I'm looking forward to that.
But right now, the next big challenge,
this is coming up soon, right?
Yeah, that's supposed to be,
I mean, I saw dates online for June 5th, June 6th,
but they, I'm not sure if they have confirmed the dates yet,
but yes, it's coming up.
It's akin to the Kipchoge experiment
so they can have Pacers and they can have,
and they can draft in the cycling leg.
So the idea is to attempt to go under seven hours
in an Ironman using all of these otherwise illegal devices.
And there was an article in cycling news the other day
that Alex Dowsett is gonna be pacing Alistair Brownlee.
Alex is a outstanding professional cyclist.
And it just kind of talks, sets the stage
for this event to come.
I thought it was just Kristian.
I didn't know that Brownlee was doing it as well.
Yeah, they're going against.
So are they the only two competitors?
As far as I know. They're the two, yes.
Right, so these guys are stacking their teams
with professional cyclists
to rotate in and out and pace them throughout this.
And Kristian has his own team.
I wasn't familiar with the guys that he's selected.
And it's gonna, it's sponsored by Zwift.
It's happening, where is it happening?
It's happening in Germany.
In Germany, yeah.
Yeah, in Germany.
On a 5.85 kilometer fixed circuit,
at least for the bike leg.
Yeah, it's all gonna be lapped, I think.
That's part of the way they make it easier
and like account for conditions.
And to put this in perspective,
these guys are gonna have to maintain a speed
between 45 and 50 kilometers per hour
over the entire 112 miles of the bike leg.
That's crazy.
The target.
Which is crazy, right?
And then after that, run a very fast marathon.
Mm-hmm, very fast.
Like sub 230, I think, like 220, right?
I don't know exactly how that balances out.
Oh, here, is it here?
No, it's not. It's not in here.
So anyway, I hope this is gonna be live-streamed somewhere.
It will be, it will be.
And I think, at this point,
it's like one of those fun things to do.
I wonder how it plays out.
But I don't think they're tapering for,
they're not like, I don't know how much of a priority is
for either of these athletes.
You talked to Olav recently, and he was saying
this is like a blip on the radar
in terms of how much they're focusing on.
I mean, they are happy to be involved in doing it,
but it's not it like, it's not the,
they're not orienting their season towards it,
because they can't.
'Cause the season is, they just did the Ironman
and he just won it, and so then they have
some 70.3s lined up, the Olympic, World Cup race in Bergen
in late August and then Kona.
So that's kind of the points
that they're orienting towards in this.
This is going to happen when the sponsors can figure out
the best timing.
And because of that, I think because it was a moving target,
it's hard to aim for.
Yeah. I don't know, man.
I think things like this go a long way
towards really engaging the broader public
in a sport that normally they overlook.
If I was scheduling this, I would try to do it at a time
where they could put a little bit more focus
and intention into it because it's such a spectacle.
I mean, look what the sub two project did for Kipchoge.
I think it put his name in a lot of people's brains,
who ordinarily would never have heard of that guy.
Like it was so mind blowing to watch him do that.
And it made his Tokyo win that much bigger.
Right, a lot more people were invested in that.
So from a PR perspective
and from a sponsor investment perspective,
I think things like this,
I think we need more stuff like this.
Like this is not dissimilar from the Chris Chavez,
Malcolm Gladwell mile showdown.
It's like these things aren't really part and parcel
of like the traditional sports competition sphere.
But it's things like this
that I think a lot of these sports need
to get other people interested in what's going on.
It makes it more fun.
Yeah, it elevates the whole sport by doing this thing.
I mean, the question is, does,
the marathon is this thing everyone can relate to,
the Ironman, you know.
It's tough to know.
And plus, I don't even know if,
is the Ironman involved in this?
They don't like their name--
No, this has nothing,
I don't think this has anything to do with Iron,
I'm sure they can't even use the word Ironman
'cause they policed that trademark.
So it's like that makes it harder.
But I hear what you're saying.
Yeah, absolutely.
It's a collab.
Yes, it is a collab.
That was the theme of this podcast, is it not?
(laughs)
Well, I'm definitely gonna be tuning in for this.
I think it's super cool.
Let's do it.
I wonder how they're gonna do the run,
because the way they did, like the Kipchoge thing was on
that Monza track in Italy, right?
Right.
Or it was on an auto track.
And it was just one giant loop.
Right.
So for this, is the cycling loop the same as the run loop?
And what is the swim situation?
Good questions.
I don't know.
I have not deep, I didn't do the deep dive.
All right, well--
But we can look at that
because I think there's gonna be a roll on
right after this, right?
Hopefully.
Yeah.
Here's an idea.
'Cause those guys are coming here right after Kona
or right before Kona.
Right after, right?
Right after, yeah.
That's perfect.
I think. Yeah, right after.
What about roll on on the road in Kona?
That could be interesting.
Some real-time reporting in Kona.
Get Talbot.
Could think about that.
This is how I--
You would have to compete
with Breakfast with Bob.
You know about Breakfast with Bob?
No, I was not.
So Bob Babbitt, who's a legend in Ironman.
Yes.
Been around forever.
(speaks in foreign language)
Everybody loves Bob.
He does a show called "Breakfast with Bob",
where all the, like, the ballers,
like, sit down with him and do a little interview.
So I don't wanna to encroach on Bob's territory.
No.
We don't wanna do that.
We'll take after, after them.
Yeah, that could be fun.
I'm gonna think about that.
And anybody who's listening or watching,
would that be something that you would be interested in?
Hey, would you like to see the RRP go on location?
Yeah, we could get a hype house.
Yes.
If only we knew someone who had a hype house in Kona.
I know.
I don't know.
All right, I'll think about that.
Speaking of hype, the last little story
that I wanna cover here, which is super interesting, is--
I love this story.
The Australian World Championship Team Trials
just took place, selecting the Australian swim team
for the world championships this summer.
And very interestingly,
Cody Simpson landed a spot on the team,
swimming 51.9 in the 100 fly.
I think he went 51.7 in the prelims.
Wow.
So for people that don't know, Cody Simpson is a pop star.
So this is the, to wrap your head around this,
this would be the equivalent of like Justin Bieber
making the Olympics.
Like this guy is a huge musical sensation.
He spent quite a bit of time in Los Angeles.
He lived here.
He's done a little bit of training here.
Last I heard, when he was living in LA,
he had a relationship with Miley Cyrus.
I think he was living with Miley Cyrus for a while.
He's dated like Kylie Jenner and Gigi Hadid like--
Wow.
This guy is like a legit celebrity.
That's mega.
Who had a background in swimming,
who's a very good swimmer.
Then he was focused on his music career.
I know that when he was in LA,
he was swimming down at USC,
training with some of the guys
who were training for the Olympics
because I was introduced to him through some mutual friends.
And I think he had made a stab
at making the Australian Olympic,
he competed at the Australian Olympic Trials,
didn't make the team.
He's 25, by the way.
25, wow.
And then comes back and lands a spot
on their world championship team and crushed it.
I mean, that's a wild story.
It's pretty rare.
I've never heard of a story like it.
It's the only thing that I can think of even recent times,
is Jake Paul becoming like a good boxer.
Right, but he's not--
But he's not--
He's not going to the Olympics in boxing.
No, he's not making Olympic team and he's not, he's also--
It's stunt boxing.
And he's also not a megastar.
So it's like, he is but through YouTube.
I don't wanna rank people, but like--
I can't think of another athlete
who is like a huge talent and celebrated for that talent
and is also like an extraordinary athletic talent.
No, you sometimes get these athletes that,
like Jim Brown was, at the height of Jim Brown's fame
as an athlete, he was the best football player in the world,
he started doing movies,
and he was in some big movies in the '60s.
So like that's probably the,
but that, again, he got the fame that made him a movie star.
It's totally different when you're the movie star
that then has to actually go through the grind
and becoming an athlete.
But who else now is like around 25,
all right, back to Timothee Chalamet.
It would be like if he suddenly made
the world championship team in the 10k,
in the 10,000 meters or something--
Right, right. It's crazy.
What a story.
The story gets
so all consuming.
You can't really do anything else
if you're gonna compete at that elite level.
And he looks like a brick house.
I mean, he looks--
Yeah, he's jacked.
He's completely jacked.
And he's got a massive like Instagram following.
And this guy's like a global celebrity
for his musical talent.
So that's wild.
I'm gonna pitch a story on.
And maybe I can--
It's a great story.
Latch on to the back of his entourage
and get five minutes of face time.
I think you could drum up a pretty interesting story
about this guy.
I'd have to get the access, that's the key.
You can swing that.
You got connects.
I'm married into an Australian, into the Australian--
That's right.
Nation.
Australians hang close to each other.
Yes, Australians have more international,
well, more camaraderie within the nation.
Well, especially when they're expats,
like in America and places like that.
That's true.
They flock together for sure.
The other big story coming out of the Australian Trials
is Ariarne Titmus, who set a world record in the 400 free,
swimming 3:56:4, breaking Katie Ledecky's world record.
I'm not sure, but is this the first one
of Katie Ledecky's world records to fall to somebody else?
I think so.
I think it is.
Should probably know the answer to that.
But you know what, it was amazing watching that
'cause her, she was at, way out front the world record,
and then watching the world record line creep up
you could almost see the,
you could almost see Katie Ledecky
just trying to track her down, you know what I mean?
'Cause she closes so strong,
Katie Ledecky, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Her back end was stronger.
Ariarne went out a little bit faster.
Good for her.
Kyle Stockwell, on Twitter,
is a great source for swimming news.
He reports like a feed.
And he posted like the comparative splits
between Titmus and Ledecky,
and it was pretty interesting to see how they differed.
He posted a great video of Titmus's coach,
which was a delight.
Oh yeah, I saw that, yeah.
Yeah, that guy was losing his mind.
He's like, "I got the Jeff Spicoli haircut."
He looked like he was like seeing his favorite rock star.
Like he almost looked like a rocker from my,
like AC/DC just showed up.
(laughs)
I know.
And I shared a little video clip of her swimming
and there's this underwater camera view of her stroke.
Oh yeah.
It's just so powerful.
So amazing.
Her SWOLF is better than mine, I'm pretty sure.
I think she has a good SWOLF.
A good SWOLF.
I still don't know what that is,
but I'm sure hers is very good.
But you know a guy who can test it.
I do.
Yeah.
I guess this thing on my wrist might be able to.
But I don't know about that.
Anyway, that's it for endurance corner.
Let's take another quick break.
And we'll be back with some thoughts on the art of memoir.
(air swooshes)
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the Plantpower Meal Planner
are affordable, all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands
of highly customizable, super delicious,
and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery.
And you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off in annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff, people,
for just a $1.70 a week.
Literally, the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com.
Promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off in annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
All right, before we get into the next thing, two thoughts.
First of all, Davey, during the break,
was quick to add that Master P played in two NBA games,
one for Charlotte and one for--
Toronto.
Toronto, is that right?
How do you do?
That's in the ballpark,
sort of, I don't know.
But you still don't know 'cause he was already Master P,
so you don't really know when he have made the squad
had he not been Master P.
Whereas this guy, like that's a great thing about swimming,
you can't make it--
Clock doesn't lie.
Right.
Yeah, who knows?
They say in basketball, "The ball don't lie."
And in swimming, they say, "The clock doesn't lie."
Is that what they say? Who's they?
Rasheed Wallace.
Ball don't lie, baby.
Well, if there's anyone else out there
that we're not thinking of, like hit us up
in the comments and let us know.
The other thing is we're discussing the possibility
of going to Kona during the break.
And it took Adam a nanosecond before he inserted
freediving into the conversation.
We could do freediving podcast and go freediving.
I got, since--
It suddenly became all about freediving.
I got certified in Kona now, as a freediver.
And they drop a line and it's about 40--
Who's the guy there again?
Well, I went with Kirk Krack.
There's a guy named, God, why am I spacing on,
is it Brett Lemaster?
There's a guy who has another freediving school there
that's not Kirk Krack.
I was there like a year and a half ago.
I think I hit you up
because my buddy Anthony Ervin was like,
oh, I'm gonna go do--
Oh right, Kurt Chambers.
So the other guy that, the third guy that is,
someone who I'm the most connected with
but I never trained with him.
So there's two freediving schools that regularly do that
in Kona now, and Kurt Chambers has his own business
and he's all over the islands,
he's like the number one guy for training people
in every island in Hawaii.
And as also the best freediver of all of those guys,
he's 100 meter plus freediver and so he's--
He has a cool Instagram as well.
Yeah, great Instagram,
great photographer and videographer.
He's in the Philippines right now, freediving.
So Kurt Chambers.
That's what I was thinking.
We could go dive with Kurt Chambers.
Right, so suddenly what if we go to Kona
during Ironman week
and all we do is go freediving and interview freedivers?
(laughs)
That seems like a bad use of budget.
I know, yeah.
Anyway. All right, switching gears here.
This week, again, it's the 10th anniversary
of "Finding Ultra", my first book.
This has given me a moment to kind of reflect
on this journey, which has been a really cool journey.
That book really set in motion
all of the things that I get to do today
and I'm very grateful for the experience
of writing that book and sharing that story with the world.
And yeah, I just kind of wanted to reflect back on that
and celebrate it.
I posted a tweet thread on Sunday
with a few things that I've learned along the way
as a result of writing this book.
Not the least of which is,
often when I get interviewed or I see press about myself,
it says, "New York Times' best-selling author,"
and I always laugh.
It's like this book was not
a New York Times best-selling book.
It never made the New York Times.
It didn't make any of those list.
Like it came out, it did fine
and it found a little bit of an audience.
And from there, it's just been a very slow build.
Obviously, the podcast has been helpful
in it reaching more people.
But just this kind of steady uptick year-after-year
of people finding the people and enjoying it and sharing it,
which is kind of like this podcast,
and it's really emblematic
of like every success that I've had.
Like I haven't had big viral moments.
Like I said in the tweet thread,
I haven't been on "Ellen" or "The Today Show"
or done a lot of mainstream stuff.
I mean, maybe the most mainstream thing
was the New York Times article that you wrote about me,
which I'm very grateful for.
That was many, many years after this book came out.
But everything that I've been able to achieve
has been a really slow burn.
And so it was kind of a meditation on leaning into that.
On the long game.
Yeah, the long, it's all about,
and as an ultra-endurance athlete, like it's fitting.
Yeah, I love that tweet thread.
I thought it was cool.
You say that the book has sold better each year
since it was published.
Yeah, I don't know if that's entirely accurate.
I know it continues to sell, and I would have to go back
and look at the specific numbers.
I'm sure there's been ebbs and flows with that.
But yeah, I mean, I just know
from getting the quarterly statements or whatever
that it continues to sell as well as it ever has.
I mean, obviously the first week it comes out
like you're gonna sell a lot
'cause it includes those pre-order numbers,
and then after that there's a huge dip.
And then from there forward,
it's just been kind of a solid growth curve.
Well, do you mind if I ask some probing questions?
Sure.
On the record?
There's no off the record here.
Never.
Is that what you tell all your sources?
No, what I tell them is,
"Anything you want off the record, just let me know."
But not you, Rich.
No. Okay, I'm game.
So tell us a little bit about
like where you were in your life
when you decided to write the book,
'cause you've already done these amazing feats,
you're already kind of, you're on the path,
you're sober, you're an endurance athlete again,
you're fit, so like what, where were you,
how many years after EPIC5, how did all come together?
It came together fairly shortly after EPIC5.
I had come back from that and was trying to figure out
what I was gonna do next.
And it was a challenging time.
Like I was still a practicing lawyer at that time
but I had lost so much interest in pursuing that
that I wasn't really making very much money doing that
and was really struggling to pay the bills
and to figure out how to provide for my family.
And the way it came together is kind of a cool story.
There had been a little blurb about me
in the Stanford alumni magazine
about how I had done these races
and it mentioned that I had been sober for a while.
And in the wake of that article coming out,
I got a email from a guy who had been a swimmer at Stanford,
who was somebody I didn't know,
he was several years older than me.
And he just said, "Listen, I saw that article
in the alumni magazine.
I'm newly sober and it would be good
to be able to talk to somebody.
Could we like talk on the phone?"
And I just called him up, or he called me.
And this guy had recently gotten out of treatment,
he's CEO of a large company,
nobody on his, in his company knew
what was going on with him
and he was trying to navigate like early sobriety
and all of the kind of challenges of that.
And I just was there to be of service to this guy
and share whatever I could to help him and that was it.
And we had a number of calls,
talked every couple of weeks for a period of time.
And at some point, he said to me like,
"You have a pretty cool story.
Like have you ever thought about writing a book?"
And I hadn't seriously ever thought of writing a book.
I had thought like,
"Maybe that would be a cool thing to do,"
but it wasn't like I had ever taken any active steps
towards pursuing that in any meaningful way.
He was like, "Oh, I know this book agent.
I should introduce you," and he did.
And that led to me being on the phone with Carole Bidnick,
who became my agent at the time.
And I told her the story, and she said,
"Well, books like this are hard.
You really have to thread the needle.
I'd be happy to read a proposal
and happy to help kinda babysit you through
how to put a proposal together if you're interested.
I can't make any promises," and that was kinda that.
But it was a crack in the, it was like a little crack,
the door cracked open a little bit.
And I've just learned over the years
when you have that little opportunity,
like those don't come around that often.
So I was like, this is something I'm gonna take
really seriously.
And I worked really hard for like three or four months
on a proposal, which entails,
it's like writing a business plan for a book, as you know,
'cause you've done it.
Like you have to create a marketing plan
and you have to synopsize the book
and you have to write a couple chapters of it
and you gotta outline the whole thing,
like you gotta kinda spell out the entire project
and also make the case
for why it's viable in the marketplace.
And I'd never done anything that before.
But I worked really, really hard on it
'cause I knew like this is a shot
that doesn't come around that often.
And when it was done, send it to her,
and she said, "This is good.
But again, like this is really hard
and I've got a couple publishing potential buyers here
who I think might be interested in this,
but like we'll see," like she was very tempered
in the whole thing.
But she said, "I'm gonna slip it to a few people
and I'll be in touch."
And literally, like within a day,
I'd got an interest from Random House, Rick Horgan,
who's editor there, who's a big editor at Crown
at the time, was interested.
And Carole's like, "Let's do a call."
And I still remember the call.
I was like at the, at this, at the Calabasas Commons,
which just like this outdoor mall,
like walking around when this call was scheduled
'cause I didn't have an office and I couldn't work at home.
We had young kids and all that kinda stuff.
And I would like go to the Barnes & Noble,
which I had free Wi-Fi at the time, to work.
And so to do this call, where it was quiet,
I remember like going behind some bushes
to like do this pitch call.
And he just said, "Tell me about this project in the book,"
and I just laid it on thick
and like threw down the best case
that I could make on the phone.
And within 72 hours, we had a deal
that he took it off the table
and like, we were like off to the races.
And Carole was like, "That never happens.
You don't understand,
like this is always a much more protracted,
challenging situation."
So it was unbelievable, like I was,
I couldn't believe that this was happening.
And so there was another kind of crack, door cracking open.
Just 'cause you wrote a book,
doesn't mean it's gonna be good or successful.
So I really busted my ass for like a year
to put this book out and make--
Did you separate yourself from your law practice entirely
during that year?
No, I was straddling both.
Because I got like an okay advance for a first time writer.
But as you know, you see like, "Oh, it's this much money,"
but it's like, okay, you get 25% on signing
and then 50% when you deliver the manuscript
and then the other like whatever percent
when the book comes out.
So this is spread out over a long period of time.
And when you take out taxes and agency commission,
like it was, I was incredibly grateful for it.
It was huge, but it wasn't a situation
that was gonna be able to sustain my family
over a period of a year and a half.
So I had to supplement my income
with still practicing law at the time.
I didn't pull the plug on practicing law
until the book came out.
And then I was like, "I'm not renewing my bar membership."
Fantastic.
So after the book came out--
Yeah, then I was like, "I'm done."
And that was scary too, because you would think,
like when the book comes out,
oh, all these opportunities happen and like you,
you got to be this guy and go tour with the book,
and it was like, yeah, I did a little bit of,
I did a couple of appearances.
A few people came to them.
It wasn't any big deal.
And then it was like crickets.
Right.
And part, one of the lines in the book
is when your heart is true,
the universe will conspire to support you.
And I was like, "My heart's fucking true,
like the universe will conspire to support me.
I believe that."
What I realized is that it wasn't gonna be on my timeline.
No, not on your schedule.
And I had to suffer for quite a long time
before things started to turn around
and I was able to like create a vocation
out of what the book began.
So the book comes out, you cancel your bar membership,
so what are you doing like in that time?
Because even if it was selling well,
which you said it was doing okay,
but you didn't sound like you're gonna be
able to live off of that.
I mean, it was dark, dude.
That was the period of time.
And I've spoken about this many, many times before
so we don't need to go into detail around it.
But we had cars repossessed.
I couldn't pay for our garbage removal
so our bins got taken away.
We were driving around in a completely beat up minivan
that had like 200,000 miles on it,
that smelled like garbage
'cause we had to put our garbage in the minivan
and then find an empty dumpster somewhere to dump them.
Like it was humiliating and emasculating.
But I'd get the occasional 500 bucks to go speak somewhere
or some little opportunity would come along.
(clears throat)
But it was dark and we were drowning.
And that's when the opportunity to go to Kauai
and work with this guy Chris Jaeb came along.
(clears throat)
He threw us a lifeline to help him figure out
how to make use of this amazing property that he owned
on the north shore of Kauai.
And we moved to the Hanalei area and lived in Yurt,
on his organic farm.
And I worked with him for three months,
trying to help him as best I could
and he paid us and that allowed us to like pay our bills.
And it was like, I'm so incredibly grateful for.
It's confusing and weird
in that like I don't know why he thought I could be the,
I was the right person to fill this strange role
that he wanted filled,
but I'm extremely grateful to him because he,
short of that, like I don't know what we would've done.
But it was, during that period of time,
which was the winter of 2012
that I started the podcast there
and that's kind of what led to everything that's followed.
Yeah, right. You started that there.
So it is related to this, to the book in that regard, right?
The book happens, you leave law,
and then things kind of tailspin
and you end up landing in Kauai,
softly in a beautiful place and then start this podcast.
Yeah.
And to be clear, like the podcast was a fun,
creative passion project.
It was never considered to be something
that would generate money
that would allow me to support my family.
And for a snapshot of what podcasting was like in 2012,
it's nothing like it is today.
Like it wasn't cool to start a podcast.
I didn't know anybody other than myself
that listened to podcasts.
It was difficult to download a podcast.
This was before the iPhone and streaming.
You had to download it on your desktop or your laptop
and then bounce it to an iPod
to create these like playlists.
It was a thing.
And at the same time, it was also a moment in time
where no, it wasn't like people were starting podcasts
all over the place.
So from the very first episode,
we were able to make an impression on iTunes
and solidify like a position in the charts
and the health space.
And that, I think, opened the door for us
to develop a listenership
in a way that would be much more difficult today.
Hmm, yeah.
I can relate to thinking, you get the book come out,
you think you made it to a certain level, and you have,
'cause it does establish kind of,
it is an establishing thing for you
because there is a perception around it,
especially if the book has either sold well
or been reviewed well, but even not,
just if it has some sort of anything around it.
Like in my case, the book,
my book didn't, "One Breath" didn't sell as well,
but it had really good reviews in some places.
And so then, but then afterwards
(laughs) you're trying to,
you have to then keep making a living, right?
And for some reason, you take your foot off the gas.
I did, I took my foot off the gas a little bit
because I wasn't like, I didn't wanna sell myself that hard.
I didn't really push the PR as hard as,
like if I had to do it again,
I think I would do things a lot differently
and I never would take my foot off the gas.
But you have to go through that to know that.
You have to be utterly shameless in that phase.
And that's not really in the wiring of most writers.
Like they write so they don't have to interact with people.
They write because they are ashamed.
(both laugh)
Well, like many artists, it's like, "I did the thing,
you go push it out into the world."
Like, "I already created my thing."
And sometimes there's an expectation
that the world is awaiting this great work.
Like nobody's waiting for your thing.
I didn't think that.
You gotta make it happen.
And I remember getting counsel from some people
who are like, "You have to do everything in your power
to make people care about this,"
and I treated that like my job,
did the best that I could with the small
sort of interest, public interest, that I had at the time.
But yeah, it kind of comes and goes.
And it's a weird dissociative experience
because on the one hand like I couldn't believe
I was being given the opportunity to write a book.
And then that book, you could go to Barnes & Noble
and see it on the shelf, it's like mind-blowing.
Right. Yeah, that was cool.
It's like I can't even believe.
This is like so cool.
Like travel to a different city and go into a bookstore
and your book is there, like wild, right?
And the fact that 10 people
would come to like hear me talk about it,
like who are these people, like that's crazy.
So that was all gravy and amazing.
But I think there's a public perception
that if you're a published author
and your book is in a bookstore
that like you don't have to worry about paying your bills
and I can tell you that that's certainly not the case.
The opposite is true.
The writing style itself, like obviously as a lawyer,
people know lawyers write a lot,
but they don't write in this particular way.
They write, a lot of lawyers write in stilted,
highly specific ways.
You were able to, in your first crack,
like I write all the time so like,
it's part of my musculature, you do now as well,
but in, often for the podcast,
but for this book, you weren't coming
from like writing every day kind of background.
Well, yes and no.
I mean, first of all, have you read my demand letters
from my lawyer days?
I would not call them stilted.
Very direct.
Writing a great, snarky demand letter
is a art form in and of itself.
You should do a collection.
Yeah, there's some great ones like, you know.
I am in receipt of your, you know.
I assure you that my client, you know, and whatever.
No, I was a creative writer long before I was a lawyer.
Like I did a lot of writing in college, I always loved it.
And law school and being a practicing lawyer
I think only enhances one's writing skill
because it lends structure to it.
It provides like a framework for making an argument
and supporting that argument
as long as you hold on to whatever
creative flare that you have.
But just the practice of always being,
writing when you're a lawyer
I think keeps that muscle strong.
But I think a lot, the sensibility of the book
has less to do with writing skill
and more about like a willingness to be vulnerable
and tell stories that most people
would maybe be too uncomfortable to show.
Right, but you tell 'em as if you're,
you're writing as you talk, which is what you should do
and so it is a very natural voice in the book.
Yeah. I mean, I don't know about you when you're writing,
but for me, the approach with this book is,
was to overwrite it, like just write everything
and then figure out what the salient stories are
and call out everything that isn't moving the story forward.
And I work with it, Rick Horgan was my editor,
but I also work with another editor
'cause I think you need that,
that sounding board or that feedback
because you're too in the middle of it,
like it's your story.
So having perspective is important as well.
But I think most memoirs suffer from lack of editing,
like there's too much in there.
It's not like,
if you're telling your, quote, unquote, "life story",
you're not supposed to say,
tell every story that ever happened to you
that's interesting.
Like what is propelling the story forward,
that pivots on the themes
that you are finding most important and telling that story?
Well, let's talk about the craft of memoir.
What do you think makes a good or great memoir?
That's a good question.
I wanna throw that to you as well,
as somebody who's written memoirs.
I mean, for me, my book kinda falls
into the sports memoir category.
Right.
And I think most sports memoirs suck.
They're terrible.
Because they're vainglorious.
Like they're generally written by a ghostwriter
in the twilight of a certain athlete's career
as an exercise in extending
that particular athlete's brand viability.
And so they tend to focus on all the great stuff
that they did, but they rarely paint a full picture
of that person's life.
Like they don't typically have the level of candor
and honesty and vulnerability that I think is critical
to connecting with a readership.
I mean, there's exceptions to that.
I think Andre Agassi's memoir is exceptional
for that reason.
So for me, I didn't wanna be influenced by that genre
so I didn't go out and read a bunch of memoirs
and try to deconstruct what would make for a good memoir.
I just tried to tell my story as openly
and as honestly as I could.
And the framework that I used for that
is sort of the what happened,
what it was like, what happened, and what it's like now,
which is like the 12-step format of sharing your story.
And somebody sat in tens of thousands of 12-step meetings
and listened to people share their stories
and I've had the opportunity to share my own
many, many times.
That was really more of where my head was at like,
"How can I tell my story in an extended version
of that format and to do it as honestly as I could?"
So that's interesting.
That's kind of a storytelling workshop for you in a way
the 12-step.
Oh, big time.
And as a podcast host.
The bridge between, the writing bridge from undergraduate
all the way to the book.
But the storytelling, the creative writing,
the storytelling and the memoir aspect is kind of like
you're soaking it in in all these meetings.
Right, and when you are in a position
where you're telling your story a lot,
it starts to tell you what it is.
And when you have an audience, you can gauge in real time
like what people are responding to,
what's important, what's not.
I think David's, that's why one of the reasons
that you wanted to spin it back,
but "Can't Hurt Me" was a success a large part
because David had been telling versions of that story
in his recruitment, for the navy's recruitment speaking gigs
during the navy when he'd go to high schools and colleges
and he'd been telling it on podcasts,
obviously starting here and then other podcasts as well.
And so he was able to do that
and he was a master of that story.
By the time he got here, you'd think you're the,
I think you were one of the first podcasts he was on,
but he'd been telling that story and versions of it
for 10 years already.
And so he was a total master of it.
And so when I got linked up with him,
my job is just to be the blank channel
and to try to channel as much of pure David into it,
so it's interesting 'cause like it it's the same idea.
You hear the story and the story starts,
you refine it and it becomes almost an organic process.
So when you were writing that book,
were there other literary reference points
that you were trying to mimic in some way,
like what were the inspirations beyond just David himself?
Well, I mean, I think David,
I'd have to put that at the top
because his story is so epic,
that you knew was gonna help a lot of people
if it's done well.
Like it's just an incredible story.
It's a real life Rocky story.
So like how often does that fall in your lap?
Sure, but in structuring it, I'm sure he told you
some incredible stories that didn't make it into the--
Oh yeah, 100%. Yeah, yeah.
So how you structure it was,
I'd have to think about it,
what was really, in terms of my approach, the only,
I didn't think about anybody else's memoir really.
The only one I can think of, of a ghost written memoir
that I really loved was
"The Autobiography of Malcolm X" and so that's--
That's a good one.
That's Alex Haley who wrote that.
And so I thought, first of all,
before David even came around, when someone asked,
when Byrd asked me if I would be interested
in ghost writing, I thought,
"Well, if Alex Haley could be interested in ghost writing,
then I certainly could be interested in ghost writing."
And so that book is one of my favorite books of all time.
I think it's the goat when you talk about memoir.
I don't think there's a better memoir ever.
And so certainly there was that.
But I didn't go back and read it.
I didn't like think about structure in that way,
because I think what I was mostly concerned about
was telling his story properly and keeping it true to him.
And so it's like as long as that's your,
your focus is on making that story, great then.
Yeah, I didn't think of it any other way
and I just tried to rely on how did I write?
'Cause I still, even though "One Breath"
didn't sell as I'd hoped, I knew it was a good book.
So how can I take what I learned there
and apply it to this and write something that's good?
So that's really my whole approach.
But I didn't have any sort of feeling how it would go
or how it would turn out.
And when you look back on "One Breath"
or even the Goggins book "Can't Hurt Me,"
do you look at it and think, "Oh, I should've done this,"
or, "I should've changed that," or are you able to just say,
"Yeah, those are great?"
Well, it's funny you say that.
With "One Breath," there was, when,
my first book proposal with "One Breath"
included me as part of the investigation.
So like the way Krakauer did into "Into the Wild".
Inserting yourself into that narrative.
And which is how most people do, well, not most.
There's been a period of time
where it's invoked to do that way or not to do it that way.
I always thought that you should tell it that way
'cause it gives the reader
someone besides the protagonist to relate to.
And those were some of my favorite books,
"Into Thin Air" especially,
but he's obviously on "The Climb",
that's almost part memoir.
But "Into the Wild", him investigating it
is part of the story.
So I thought that was gonna be it.
But then when we got the deal,
the editor at Crown didn't want that.
He wanted it to be more like "Shadow Divers,"
which is this story where the journalist is the channel
but is not in the story.
And then I read a book
called "Behind the beautiful Forevers"
by, I think it's Katherine Boo, which is a masterpiece.
And that was kind of one of the first nonfiction books
I'd read in a long time, where there was no,
the journalist wasn't there but obviously was there.
It's all about the Mumbai slums
and the people that live in the Mumbai slums,
but it's a beautiful book.
And so I thought that she's the ticket
so I've paid attention there.
But in terms of memoir, I didn't do it.
I mean, I've liked, I've loved some memoirs.
I love "Eat, Pray, Love" obviously.
Elizabeth Gilbert, I think she's set the standard,
and a lot of books that we've seen since then
owe their existence to "Eat, Pray, Love".
"A Heartbreaking Work of Staggering Genius"
by Dave Eggers was--
Sure.
Monumental, love that.
I love "The Zanzibar Chest",
which is probably out of print now, by Aidan Hartley,
which was great, a journalist that worked for,
in the '90s in Africa,
all the wars in Africa and covered those.
So there are definitely some memoirs I loved,
but I didn't really look at them
when I was taking on David's story.
Was that a conscious decision?
Yeah. I mean, I don't,
that's a good question.
I just didn't think that they had,
I didn't, my, I needed to tune into David.
It's different when you're writing a book
that's your byline and that you're taking on.
I think you have more, there's more latitude.
But this time, I needed to tune into David.
And so that's what I did.
So I spent all my time tuning in there.
The book that I would add to that list,
which is a great list (clears throat), is Murakami's
"What I Think About When I Think About Running."
Right.
Which is definitely a touchdown for me.
But I think I, the other thing that was going on
when I was writing this book is, it's kinda funny,
is that around the time that my book was announced,
it was also announced that Scott Jurek was writing a book.
Right.
So Scott Jurek, being the reigning king of ultrarunning
and also a plant-based athlete was a pretty heavy blow
and semi-demoralizing to me.
I mean, nothing but love for Scott,
but I'm thinking we're writing these, like, dueling memoirs
at the same time like, "Why would anyone read my book?"
Like, "They can read Scott's book.
He's the king.
I've never even won a race.
I can't even believe I have a book deal,
like given that I'm not like a world champion athlete
or anything like that."
It was confusing.
It's like, "Oh, I'm gonna write this book."
Like, "What is the way in,"
or, "What is the reason that I can give somebody
to read this book?"
And I realized, or I settled on this notion
that I think was really fundamental and important,
which is the success or failure of my book
would be directly correlated
to the extent to which I was willing to be vulnerable.
Because the story I wanted to tell
was a more relatable human story,
an aspirational story versus an inspirational story.
And my ability to connect with the reader,
that connective tissue, would be forged
through kind of sharing things I'm not proud of
in hopes that that would like breed
some level of recognition, like some,
so that anybody reading it,
who's harboring some kind of pain or secret themselves,
could say, "Well, I relate to that guy."
Or there's a part, even though the details of,
this is another like 12-step thing,
like even though the details of that story
are very different from mine,
like I identify with the feelings and the emotions.
And so I used that as kind of a north star.
Yeah, that's why, like I, it's funny.
I mean, it's very different book,
but "Eat, Pray, Love" kinda came to mind
when I was reading this because she,
that's one thing, I think,
that made that book so successful.
Right, right.
And so you followed in that track,
which I think is a great track.
I love that book.
And I think Liz is amazing.
And I know she's a friend of yours.
Like I just think she's the best.
She's the coolest.
Yeah, yeah.
Especially when her and Rob Bell get together,
like it's unbelievable.
But she got a lot of shit for that book, right?
Later.
But like at first it was--
Was that because of the Oprah thing
or the movie or, what was it?
Well, I think, I mean, first, the book
was a cultural touchstone.
So I think anytime you get so big, the haters come.
So I think what happened at first was the book came out,
it made the list, it was doing all right,
she was going around, the bookstores,
just like we described.
And I went to a reading at Borders when,
I don't even think it's still there on La Cienaga,
and maybe like 50 people were there.
So it's not a bad turnout at all.
But it wasn't like, and then like,
I think six months later, or maybe several months later,
she told me she was with a publicist
going to a reading in San Diego
and that she had just done Oprah
and there was like lines around the block
and that's when everything changed for her
and she became monumental.
And so for a long time it was very,
I don't think there was anything negative
and then I think maybe that backlash came later.
I don't know what it was.
It was, she was misdefined
as like being some rich person who had gone on this trip,
which was not true.
She was doing fine as a writer 'cause she's a great writer,
but she wasn't like this, she wasn't not self-made.
So there was a lot of bullshit backlash,
but that comes, I think, when you get certain,
when you get big, and that's what happens.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, speaking of bullshit, let's talk a little bit
about the publishing world.
(laughs)
Well, I wanted--
'Cause like I did not have the experience
of going on Oprah and having lines around the block.
I had a very different experience.
But I think it beckons like a little bit of discussion
around like how publishing works
and this is a little inside baseball,
but I think it's interesting
and I think people who read books
would find this interesting
if they're not already aware of it.
As I mentioned, like my book didn't make
the New York Times bestseller list,
it's had this low build, it continues to,
I mean, it's still like in top categories on Amazon,
particularly the audiobook--
That's amazing.
Like it's still number one, two, or three
in cycling, in running, in triathlon and stuff like that.
Amazing.
Which is great, but on the whole
like New York Times bestseller thing,
like I know from going through this process many times,
and also by dint of hosting authors
who have books coming out on the podcast
because now podcasting has become like a de rigeur stop
on the book publishing tour.
Like you have to go on these shows
and then we try to work with authors
so that the episodes come out around the book's release.
And I do the best I can.
I can't always commit to that.
But I understand that they're here
to try to get their book out into the world
and I certainly don't begrudge anyone that--
Like I'd be doing exactly the same thing.
So the way it works is there's a pre-order period
and then there's the publishing week.
And all book orders during that pre-order period
and including that first week after publication
all books come out on Tuesday, for some weird reason--
Right.
Are counted towards first week sales.
And that first week sales number
is what gets fed to the New York Times
and has a lot to do with how they crunch the numbers
and decide who makes that, who makes it on to the list.
What people don't know is that this system
is very easily gained.
Like you can literally buy your way
on to the New York Times bestseller list,
and many, many people do it.
I don't know, I know that like now
people are more aware of this
and perhaps the New York Times and other people
that compile these lists have precautionary members
to weed out bad actors, but at least the last time,
or when "Finding Ultra" came out,
like there's, there's like companies
that you can cut them a big check
and then they go and purchase the book
through all the varying outlets
at specified periods of time.
So they take your money and they use it
to buy your own book.
And the way it works is you can't just bum-rush Amazon
and buy a ton of books.
Like you gotta spread it out
through all the different online retailers, et cetera
so that it doesn't look like there's a bad actor.
There are people that know how to do these.
Do you burn your own book?
I don't know.
Who gets the books?
I mean, I can't imagine doing this,
but a lot of people do this so that they have huge numbers
during that pre-order period and during first week
and then they end up on the bestseller list.
But it's a complete, it's like fake news, right?
Right, right, right.
Like they've just bought their own book
and so their book disappears the following week,
no one's ever heard of it again.
At the same time, like I know a lot of CEOs
or high-net-worth people that put out books particularly
like business books or how-to books.
They can, because they're high-net-worth people,
can just buy their own book
and then like either give it to their staff
or resell the book when they do public speaking appearances.
So they're like, they double dip on it
but they buy a gigantic stash that they sit on
and can kind of sell over time
and that has the similar effect.
Interesting.
So it's crazy.
So that's why you'll see a book appear
and then you'll never hear about that book ever again.
That's a pretty good indication that,
and I would imagine that the New York Times
is probably much better at trying to figure out
who's doing this and who isn't.
Yeah. Also, I think, I'm pretty sure I don't have,
I don't know for a fact, but I'm pretty,
almost positive that also the New York Times
doesn't have like, it's not just about who sold the most,
they have like certain criteria,
like they're skewed against--
There is a weird subjectivity that gets injected to that.
Yeah, and I don't know what it is.
But like it's not really just straight who sold.
Not exactly.
It's not pure numbers.
Right.
And also, what is the current status
or their stance on self-published books, Adam?
Right. Well, they,
I mean, I don't think "Can't Hurt Me"
got a fair shake on that list at all.
Like it was--
So they did it,
was it ever on the list?
It was.
It was on the list, but it was like--
Interesting.
I thought that it wasn't--
So they have an audio list
and it was never on the audio list
even though we were,
we're still getting like one of the top
listened to audiobook still.
Audible's the main platform and we were, at the time,
like number two for months.
It was like you and--
And Michelle Obama.
Michelle Obama.
And then so I don't think we got a fair shake there.
It was on the general list maybe once
and then it was on the self-help list.
And so it was nice to be on the list and be recognized,
but it wasn't a fair shake because,
and I don't think it was reflective of the sales.
Yeah.
Yep.
Yeah, it's interesting how that works.
I mean, 'cause I just remember when it first came out.
I mean, obviously like it was selling like crazy
and it wasn't on the list.
Still, yeah.
But I believed at that time they had a policy
that self-published books were not eligible.
Exactly, and maybe that's over
because they're starting to cover self-published books
a little bit differently.
But like, what I loved about your thread was,
and talking about the long game,
is it ultimately doesn't matter
because what mattered more
is like what you're building towards.
And you said it yourself on your thread
that looking back that, that vanity phase,
doesn't even matter when you're talking about actually
influencing people and having people read it
and enjoying the book.
Yeah. I mean, I'm really proud of the fact
that it has become a perennial seller.
And that's very meaningful.
Like, "Who's buying your book 10 years later?"
seems like a more important metric, but less sexy
because I can't call myself a New York Times bestseller--
It's very uncommon, though, 10 years later, very.
Is there anything you would do differently, looking back,
in terms of what you included in the book,
any passages that stand out or things that--
I mean, 100%.
I don't think that you've grown as a human being
if you can look back on a creative work
and be satisfied with it.
I mean, I'm proud of it,
and I'm not about to like rewrite it again,
but, and I don't go back and crack it
'cause there's a certain cringe factor with that like--
You can't be seen doing that.
I don't listen to my own podcast.
You can't have your children running to you
reading your own book.
Yeah, no.
I mean, look, I don't need to.
But yeah, there's tons of stuff that I would change.
I think as you grow and you mature
and also you get a sense of like
what was important about that or meaningful and what wasn't.
And I had an opportunity to comb through it
a couple years ago when I rewrote it
and I took out a ton of stuff
that I couldn't even believe
that I included the first time around.
And I think today, if I was to go back and rewrite it,
the main thing I would do would be to just make it
a pure memoir and get rid of all the appendices
and all the kind of lifestyle stuff and that
'cause that's almost like a second book
and just make it a pure memoir
as opposed to this hybrid memoir
kind of lifestyle guide aspect that it has to it,
which I think is helpful to a lot of people--
But that might have got the,
that got people interested in,
and that probably helped you sell it.
But maybe it should've been, maybe, maybe.
But maybe that should've been a second book.
Maybe the title isn't great
and maybe I shouldn't be running on the cover.
No.
There seems to be some--
Come on.
Some conflicting opinions about that.
But I think when, I think it suffered from the fact
that when it came out with its title and the title image
that people thought it was a book about running,
which it kinda is but it really isn't.
No, right.
So I don't know that it really sells
the crux of what the book is about
and perhaps that was a barrier that prevented it
from breaking out a little bit more broadly.
At the same time like, I don't know.
I think I would,
I mean, I think I have a better grasp on the story.
And with some maturity, I have a better understanding
of some of the things that I went through
and I could like write to that a little bit more eloquently
and maturely than I did at the time.
Yeah, right.
'Cause distance always creates that.
I wouldn't change it whole cloth,
but I think I would take out any, like the first time,
the first edition of the book that came out,
I had like, "Here, you can find my protein powder.
Here," like stuff like that.
I was like, "I can't believe I put that in the book."
Like, "That had no place in the book."
Especially if you want to write something
that's gonna stand the test of time,
like get rid of all that nonsense
and just write a great story.
What about any plans for a future book by Mr. Rich Roll
through the publishers?
I know you're putting out these great books.
Yeah, I really great books do wanna write another book
and I definitely have another book in me.
The challenge is my life is so busy and full.
Like when I wrote "Finding Ultra", I had nothing going on.
I was, like I'm writing this book,
and I would just write it all day.
Now, like I'm occupied all day long, every single day.
I can't imagine being able to carve out time
to write a book.
I don't know how people with busy lives do that,
like there's no way it's gonna happen without help.
That's where the ghostwriters come in.
I know, I know.
But then I'm not a big fan of this--
I'm gonna have to work with,
but then it's the control thing.
It's like, "I'm a writer,"
like, "Why would I have somebody else help me write a book?"
But the reality is, yes, you may be,
consider yourself a writer, but like without,
it's either like hold onto that and never write another book
or accept help, work with somebody else,
and get another book out in the world.
I don't love this trend of social media star
with huge following plus ghostwriter formula,
because I don't think that produces books
people wanna read that much.
But I mean, obviously I understand why publishers do it,
'cause they're trying to get sure things, but I'm not sure.
I would love to see like an audit,
how well that does for the publishers.
But in your case, no, I mean, I think,
I think you can have a ghostwriter and still write,
obviously still write something that people wanna read
because it's a matter of how you tell the story.
And I don't think that,
I think that having been through that,
my job is to stay out of the way and channel
as much from whoever's telling me the story
and who's really the author of the book
and the author of the story
and who lived that life and be blank.
And so I think if you find someone who can do that,
but I just don't think that always happens.
I think it's, to your first point
about people with social media followings and ghostwriters,
it depends on the individual.
Like, how interesting is that person?
What is the story they're gonna tell?
And most people aren't writers.
So they benefit from having a really good writer
help them crack that story open.
Like what you do, what Neil Strauss does,
like they elevate everything,
you elevate everything that you're involved in.
So there's a real value to that.
I think the ghostwriter thing
could be a little bit more transparent in certain cases.
I don't like it when you see somebody who's a celebrity
or somebody with a big following and they pass it off
like they wrote the entire book,
and I know that they didn't
'cause I know from behind the scenes
that they got help from person X, Y, or Z.
Just be honest about it.
Well, I think Barack Obama outed Michelle Obama
for having a team of ghostwriters.
Did he?
Yeah, I think (laughs).
What happened there?
He was trying to explain.
I don't know this.
I think he got, he was trying to say
like why it took so long for his book to come out
while her book was just dominating the charts.
And he's like--
Did he actually wrote it?
Yeah, yeah, he wrote it.
I mean, he wrote his first book
when he was in college, right?
Yeah, yeah, he wrote it.
In law school?
Yeah, he wrote it. Yeah, yeah.
So I don't know.
So that's kind of the,
I mean, if I was gonna write another book,
what do you think that book should be?
You want me to pitch you your next book?
Yeah.
I won't tell you where my head's at with it,
but I wanna hear what you think.
True crime.
Lean into true crime.
That's interesting.
I think it would be the second phase like what,
how do you, what happens in the years
after "Finding Ultra", building the podcast business,
inside look at what the podcast
because I think there hasn't been that book yet,
describing early days of the podcast business
and how that goes.
And you can do that while at the same time kind of
turning 50 and being in that and having,
kind of dealing with even your injury
that you're dealing with now
and I think all of that would result
in some interesting kind of storytelling.
Yeah, I don't know how to crack that open.
But don't you think that that's the subject matter?
I think it would be, I don't know.
I mean, is there enough story there?
I think it would be more along the lines
of picking certain subjects or topics
from longevity to gratitude to acceptance to--
Oh, like one of those.
And then kind of doing--
Not memoir, not memoir.
Doing some storytelling within
like having each chapter be on a different kind of concept.
Like a blue zones but with multiple concepts.
I don't know.
Blue, no, there's no travel involved to Sardinia,
I don't think.
(Adam laughs)
You're gonna stay in Malibu?
The blue zones of human experience.
Of Malibu (laughs)?
Blue zones of Malibu.
Yeah. See, here's the problem, Adam.
I don't know.
You haven't figured it out?
Yeah, I haven't.
You can always just go fishing.
I know that, listen, I know there's another book in there.
I have yet to crack what it is.
And I think that I would be asleep at the wheel
if I didn't figure out another way to birth another project.
But you just told a story about being broke ass
and having to take your growing garbage out in the minivan,
I mean, like, and then starting the podcast.
Little bit about that in the revised
and updated version of "Finding Ultra",
which you would know if you didn't,
weren't sitting there with the old version.
(Adam laughs)
I read the one, I tried to order that protein powder.
Yeah, I know, right?
I still get emails like, "Where can I get that thing?"
I was like, "I discontinued that a long time ago."
I can't believe I put that in.
I'm so ashamed of that.
No, whatever, dude.
Like your editor could've helped you.
Yeah. I don't know, man.
But look, I'm really proud of the book.
I can't believe that people are,
it's still finding audiences 10 years later.
And as I said in the tweet thread,
it is indicative of kind of everything
that I've been able to succeed at in life.
It's just this idea of staying true to who you are
and doubling down on your instinct of what's right for you
and being patient and not getting caught up
in externalities.
Because we do overindex on accolades
and starting on benchmarks
and we mistake them for meaningful predictors
of long-term success, while we remain blind
to the greater opportunity to kind of patiently
and persistently build a solid foundation
for sustainable success over time.
And I would've loved to have come out with a splash
and had a Liz Gilbert experience
that's not what happened.
And I realize in retrospect
that what happened was supposed to happen
and I'm very grateful for the way that had unfolded.
Also, I wouldn't have been able to emotionally handle that
and I probably would've imploded
had I had that kind of success.
Yeah, yeah. I mean, that's like once,
that's once or twice in a generation type success.
Nobody makes books like that anymore,
like with a touch of their signature
help open up a whole audience for books.
Like I don't even, I mean there's several people
that are doing it, Reese Witherspoon is doing it in her way.
Yeah, she's sort of the heir apparent.
There's book Instagram influencers like in that world,
they're doing it.
But I don't know if anyone,
if there will ever be another time like Oprah had
with the Oprah's Book Club, where she really--
Anointing the new--
She really had an incredible influence on a lot of people,
which is, speaks to the trust that she created
through her audience and through the work she'd done
for her whole life.
So it's cool that that happened.
But in the end, the book has to be great
or you're not gonna get someone like Oprah interested
and like she was recommending great books.
She was really reading 'em and really loving 'em
so there's also that.
It wasn't contrived.
I feel like Reese Witherspoon
is really shouldering that mantle--
Yeah, yeah, she's the closest, yeah.
But I don't think you can accurately say,
I mean, she did help with, I think, Crawdads,
which is a, what's, let me make sure I get the title right,
which is one of the best novels I've read in a long time.
"Where the Crawdads Sing" by Delia Owens.
I thought that might've been a,
that might've been an, a Reese recommend,
but I'm not 100% sure.
And that is a magnificent book.
Right, cool.
Any final thoughts before we close this out?
Well, no. You've got a giveaway, right?
Yes.
Tell us about the giveaway.
So first of all, I just wanna thank everybody
who has taken a chance on this podcast
or taken a chance on this or any of the other books
that I've put out or my wife and I have put out together.
I just can't even believe that I get to like do this thing
and live this life.
Super grateful for everything,
all the hardships and the successes.
I just get to wake up every day and come and be here
with people like you and it's a gift, man.
It's such a gift.
And I have to like remind myself of that when it gets hard
or I get grumpy or I don't sleep well
or my back hurts or whatever.
But it's really all because of you guys, the audience,
who have basically allowed me to continue to do this.
And it's incredible, man, so I'm super grateful
and thank you.
Also, I should point out, though,
that all of the book continues to sell.
The readership for "Finding Ultra"
is still a tiny fraction of the podcast audience
so there's a lot of people who listen to
or watch this podcast who have not read the book.
So maybe this 10-year anniversary celebration
is a good reason for you to finally check it out.
There's a lot in the book that,
stuff I don't talk about on the podcast.
And I just think whether you're an ultrarunner
or a plant-based person or not
or you struggle with addiction,
it's really a story of trying to find out who you are
and overcome obstacles in your life
to be more authentically you.
And the template is ultra-endurance
and the template is recovery.
So the facts of my experience may not be any,
even the least bit similar to your lived experience,
but hopefully there's something emotionally in there
that you connect with.
And like I said, the 10th anniversary of the book
is a good time or excuse to check it out.
And to kinda sweeten that,
we decided that we would do a giveaway.
So I'm gonna giveaway 50 personally inscribed copies
of the book to 50 winners.
If you would like to enter the giveaway,
you need to subscribe to my newsletter.
To do that, you can go to richroll.com/subscribe.
Basically you just provide your email address,
you joining the mailing list.
And then in the next couple days
we'll send out an email to everybody who is a subscriber
with further instructions on how to like enter the giveaway.
We've set a deadline of June ninth to secure an entry.
There's no purchase necessary.
We have official rules that will uprise you of.
So anybody can be entered to win without buying anything.
Again, richroll.com/subscribe.
And I should say on that point,
we've had an email list for quite some time
and, historically, we've used it just to send out an email
every time there's a new podcast out
and then, occasionally, an email about like a rebate
or a deal on the Plantpower Meal Planner
or something like that.
But I think I'd like to figure out a way
to make more productive use of this email list
and the subscriber base
so I'm interested in what you guys,
the audience, the listeners, the viewers would like to see,
like would you like to receive an email from me?
And if so, what would be included in that email
that would be valuable to you?
And I think I've been reluctant to pursue this A,
for bandwidth reasons
because like it would be additional work for me,
but also at the same time
I'm sensitive about sending people emails,
like everybody's email inbox is overflowing at this point,
but we're also in a period of time
where people are creating Substacks
and kind of subscription newsletters
so there is a receptivity to receiving something
that would actually be helpful and valuable
and I'm interested in trying to figure out
what that might be for all of you guys.
So if you have some thoughts,
you can tweet at me @richroll
or send an email through the website
or DM me or leave a comment on the YouTube video.
See, listeners, other people say don't at me,
Rich says at me.
Right, I mean, I'm not saying
I'm gonna get back to everybody.
But I'm interested in soliciting everybody's input
because I don't wanna create something and send it out
if that's not what people are interested in.
Right, right. I know, I like that.
Because I don't want to be, I don't take it frivolously.
It should be--
No, no, no.
Yeah, it should be valuable.
Well-thought-out if I'm gonna do that.
Yeah, it's not just about
like putting something out there,
it's putting something out there that could be of use.
Right.
Yes.
Love that.
I think that's it, dude.
Did we do it?
I think we did it.
How about that?
All right, well, we'll be back in two weeks
with another "Roll On".
Yes.
In the meantime, be well everybody.
Any final--
And roll on.
Parting thoughts?
Me? No, I have zero parting thoughts.
But see, do I have parting thoughts?
I think one of my, oh, you know what?
I got into Succession.
I finally did it.
Oh you did?
I finally started liking it.
So we haven't outlined like what we've been enjoying.
We didn't get to that today.
I got a lot of racks and lots of picks.
We gotta get next time.
You're in a deep cut, though.
Next time.
Dude, I'm like in the office all day, into the night.
You're on the grind right now.
I'm on the grind, but it's gonna be worth it.
And then we can talk about it at some stage.
Right, yeah, maybe next time
we'll share what we've been enjoying.
I've been enjoying some cool stuff at the moment.
Right on.
And with that, I bid you adieu.
Adieu.
See you in two weeks.
Peace.
(mumbles)
(mellow music)